ich will dass sie nicht
hamburg ist die zweitgrößte stadt
deutschlands
sie hat den größten seehafen des landes
jährlich legen etwa 12.000 schiffe hier
an
die hansestadt steht neben tradition
aber auch für innovation
vielleicht macht gerade das die
hamburger so glücklich einer studie
zufolge leben in hamburg die
glücklichsten deutschen
natürlich haben wir ein bisschen angst
die drei kandidaten kennen die straße
mit den vielen nachtclubs und kneipen
mit der aufgabe die sie heute bestehen
müssen hat die reeperbahn allerdings
nichts zu tun
haltet euch beim stand up paddeln eine
runde auf dem surfbrett
das ist ein bisschen angst habe
feuchte schwimmen kann aber sei alles
geld eric kann nicht schwimmen wird er
die aufgabe trotzdem schaffen
erst mal schauen wie es die profis
machen
ich bin sehr trendsportart ist direkt
vor hier vor der tür und 5 minuten in
der nähe
dann stelle ich mich drauf und machen
das wie ein ganzkörper workout
ich gehe nicht ins finde studium sondern
gehen lieber richtig raus hat meinen
spaß auf draußen auf dem wasser und
einfach cool
den gibt es eigentlich schon viel viel
länger als wir ihn jetzt hier auf der
alster zum beispiel betreiben früher
auch schon auf hawaii zum beispiel haben
sich surflehrer auf boards gestellt und
ein paddel als hilfe genommen um
wendiger zu sein sozusagen
geschicklichkeit und mut sind heute also
gefragt besonders bei eric des staates
noch sieht er ganz entspannt aus
sehr schön
die australische surferin nicole hat man
üben keine probleme
zu beginn läuft bei dem team alles nach
plan
aber dann hatte angst er habe ja immer
zum glück ist ja sehr sehr schnell
das ist für ihn ganz neu wasser ist neu
so ein brand ist neu
da fällt mir auf dass wir das viel zu
sehr voraussetzung bei den leuten sonst
da muss man vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
trockenübungen sonst vorher noch mal
genug gehört
dann habt ihr jetzt die möglichkeit eure
drei tickets zu gewinnen
ein moderner beginnt zwei bojen muss sie
im stehen umkreisen und dabei eine
flasche aus dem wasser holen
eric ist der nächste ehrlich zu gewinnen
das ist wirklich ganz ganz neu
das habe ich hier indexspitze
sowas nicht nach dem sturz bei den
proben muss eric jetzt sehr mutig sein
aber er kann sich nicht halten zwar
zieht eric die flasche aus dem wasser
aber nicht im stehen leider kein ticket
die ehemalige rettungsschwimmerin nicole
schafft den parcours dagegen problemlos
oder nicole löst alle herausforderungen
souverän und holt ticket nummer zwei für
das team auch eric freut sich obwohl er
heute leer ausgegangen ist
gesamt punktestand ausgleich 22
solch einen sport machen dann richtig
dass sie komisch das haben wir auch noch
rein aber ich finde es schon gut und
mutig dass die das machen auch wenn es
regnen und auch wenn es kalt ist ergeben
sich nur durch vor zu machen und das
geben und das bin ich schon schon cool
respekt
berlin
sie erzählt